We Begin this morning with the banking
Blame Game a week after the second
largest bank collapse in U.S history
Regulators are facing criticism for
missing warning signs that Silicon
Valley Bank was bound for implosion
President Biden is now calling on
Congress to expand his administration's
authority to crack down on Executives
who mismanaged contrib mismanagement
rather contributed to bank failures many
Republicans are resisting new rules and
some Senate Democrats are also divided
on whether a 2018 rollback of
regulations led to the current bank
failures and if passing new ones is
truly necessary fears of another
meltdown rattled Wall Street on Friday
the Dow and s p both tumbled more than
one percent the NASDAQ plunged nearly
three quarters of a percent Christina
raffini is at the White House Christina
updated us on everything you know
good morning Michelle well as you
mentioned President Biden is urging
Congress to come together and come up
with consequences for the people in
charge of these big Banks when they take
just too much risk
yes
while celebrating St Patrick's Day with
the Irish Prime Minister and the Speaker
of the House President Biden made a call
for bipartisanship there's no reason why
we can't find Common Ground the
administration is urging Congress to
work together to expand the fdic's
ability to claw back compensation from
Executives in charge of failed Banks
imposed civil fines against them and bar
those Executives from working in the
banking industry again this week the
justice department launched a probe into
the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank in
California the Wall Street Journal
reports the firm's CEO and CFO both sold
stocks just days before the bank's
failure this week the government took
decisive and forceful actions to
stabilize and strengthen public
confidence in our financial system on
the hill Thursday treasury secretary
Janet Yellen defended the
administration's decision to work with
the Federal Reserve and FDIC to raise
the usual 250 thousand dollar cap and
reimburse any depositor of the two
failed Bank they are setting up a
two-tiered system even though taxpayers
will not be on the hook for the cost
Republicans have been critical of the
bailout saying it's due to excessive
lobbying and not good policy making it
looks like there's just a lot of
political engagements here between these
two Banks and so they get bailed out
other entities don't but Democrats argue
that doing nothing wrong wasn't an
option we must do everything we can to
protect our banking system and to
prevent a Cascade of bank failures
and this week another midsize Bank First
Republic shows signs of trouble it was
propped up with billions in deposits
from other financial institutions the
fear here of course Nancy is a knock-on
effect with consumers losing confidence
in the banking system
a major worry there Christina thank you